winners give up all the time never give
up is bad advice real winners won't
hesitate to walk away from an
unsuccessful venture master the art of
moving on by learning when to quit and
when to keep going have you heard the
one about the athlete who faces obstacle
after obstacle refuses to give up and
finally overcomes the odds in the end to
win the gold it makes her a great movie
but in reality most people who aspire to
become professional athletes fail
it's simple math really for someone to
win many others have to lose fortunately
when it comes to finding the work you
were born to do you don't usually have
to compete against thousands of other
people and if something isn't working
you don't need to keep going in fact you
probably should real winners give up all
the time many people who try and try
again only to come short of a big
victory never really recover sometimes
even the ones who do make it struggle
later with any kind of meaningful second
act the real secret is that selective
quitting is a powerful practice you just
need to learn when to give up and when
they keep going you may be familiar with
this old adage often attributed to
Albert Einstein the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
Einstein was right in that the real
danger of going insane or just failing
over and over doesn't usually come from
doing something new rather the worst
failures come from doing something that
we've been doing for a while most of us
are smart enough to realize that if we
try something new
doesn't work we can't just keep doing
the same thing and expect different
results we might try it once more but
we'll usually switch up the tactic even
mice and a maze will learn to adapt an
attempt different solution if they hit
the same dead end enough times when the
stakes are low make changes or give up
quickly don't waste time on small things
and when the stakes are low make changes
right away fight your fear of missing
out while fear of missing out is a very
normal and natural human emotion it can
be dangerous if it prevents you from
quitting when it's long past time to
give up after all if you want to be
successful you can't live your life out
of fear ignore sunk costs as much as
possible it doesn't matter how much
you've invested in something whether
time money or any other resource next
time you're at the grocery store and a
better line opens up take it use the
answers to two questions that guide your
decisions ask yourself these two basic
questions 1 is it working - do you still
enjoy it you don't need to overthink
these questions and you shouldn't
sugarcoat the answers you'll be far more
successful in the long term if you're
honest with yourself about each of them
contrary to popular belief if you want
to win you shouldn't always just keep
going you should regroup and try
something totally different winners
never quit and quitters never win is
alive to win sometimes you need to find
a new game to play
winners give up all the time
[Music]